yeah so making you all see the speaker
notes was not part of the plan
um but uh I'm glad to be here and uh my
name is
and I am a reset scientist in the health
aide team at Google
uh a little bit more about me uh growing
up in India my parents always wanted me
to be a doctor to be precise a medical
doctor but unfortunately I was probably
not good enough to memorize all the
biology textbooks uh that you had to do
in case you wanted to crack the medical
insurance examinations
um so I ended up becoming a computer
scientist instead
uh but as a great man once said uh you
can't connect the dots looking forward
you only join them looking backwards so
through other long-winded path
not too dissimilar from how we actually
train our neural networks
um I've ended up working in medicine
again uh this time armed with this
magical new tool of AI and I can tell
you that my parents are far more happy
with my life choices right now
aside uh my goal for this talk is to
peel back the curtains and give you a
flavor of all the Innovation that is
happening at the intersection of AI and
biomedicine and how that is being
catalyzed by Transformers and large
language models in particular
um so we will spend the first few
minutes trying to work up from first
principles why Transformers and large
language models are a particularly good
fit for biomedical data and then we will
Deep dive into a few papers covering a
bunch of different biomedical
application settings
and finally I'll present my views on how
this field is likely going to evolve in
the next few years
and even though my voice or tone may not
exactly sound that way I am incredibly
excited by the possibilities of AI and
biomedicine and I think we have an
incredible opportunity in front of us to
advance human health and human potential
and my hope at the end of this talk is
you all will feel the same way as I do
today and perhaps join me
so yeah let's jump straight in why
Transformers in biomedicine and sorry
I'm going to pick people who are in
person to answer so maybe if one of you
could volunteer
foreign
application setting
yeah a great one so I think all of you
were on the right track and so
maybe if you just look at different
kinds of uh you know biomedical data for
example what are clinical nodes I think
it's sequence of Dr gibberish okay I did
not say that but uh let's just call it
sequence of doctor speak or doctor notes
uh similarly if you were to look at
electronic medical records what are they
they're essentially sequence of like a
person's encounters with the medical
system
um
what about proteins uh going deeper into
the biological stack uh they are nothing
but a sequence of amino acids linked
together by peptide bonds
and uh does anybody know what this is
I'll go for it I think that's how we
store medical records
[Music]
sorry again well that's like
you're getting close
anyone else
um so this is uh in the welcome
collection in London and this is
actually a printout of the full human
genome
um and uh
no they did not cheat over here the font
is super small and as you can see
there's a bunch of atgcs
um the the entire printout contains I
think uh over 130 volumes in that shelf
uh and each page is printed on both
sides and it's a four point uh font uh
with precisely 43 000 characters uh per
page so that is how big the human
reference genome is more than billions
of base pairs
and so again the genome is nothing but a
sequence of nucleotide base pairs um so
what we are essentially seeing over here
is sequences are everywhere in
biomedical data and what is the best
neural network architecture for modeling
them
um
and I guess since you are all in this
course I don't have to convince you that
the answer is Transformers right
okay that's good
um but maybe I'll just offer a few uh
reasons over here firstly as you can see
uh the data itself is multimodal in
nature
um and we just saw a few examples and as
someone pointed out Transformers have
proven remarkable at you know guzzing up
pretty much any kind of data uh and we
are really seeing this remarkable
convergence across Fields whether that's
speech or enthalpy or Vision or robotics
I mean pretty much everywhere we are
using Transformers and I think
biomedicine is no different
uh I think secondly Transformers are far
more effective at modeling uh complex
long-range interactions over sequences
and this property is particularly
important in the biomedical domain and
we will cover this in more detail later
in the talk
and finally as again someone pointed out
these data sets can be quite big and you
can easily get into the billions of
token strategy and this is where
Transformers with all the parallelizable
operations and the relative ease of
training and maybe someone should try
training an lstm and an RN on these kind
of data sets uh we'll realize that these
are much better suited for the kind of
data sets that we have in this domain
over here
so yeah I think there are a few more
reasons as well but I think these are
the key uh ones as to why Transformers
are particularly uh well suited for
biomedical data sets and tasks
um any questions so far
okay great
um so now in the next part of this talk
uh we will dive deep into a few papers
applying Transformers to uh biomedical
data
um we'll start with clinical
applications first and then go gradually
deeper into the biology stack looking at
proteins and genomic applications as
well and what you'll observe is that
while Transformers and large language
models by extension are a great fit uh
often you have to innovate not just on
the modeling side but also on the data
and evaluation side to you know make
these applicant scenarios really work
um and so the first paper I want to talk
about over here is this recent work from
our team called large language models in
code clinical knowledge uh the
motivation for this work is actually
quite straightforward so if you look at
medicine it is a Humane Endeavor and
languages at the heart of it
facilitating interactions between people
and those who provide care for them
unfortunately if you look at a lot of
medical AI systems developed till date
these are all narrow single task single
domain models lacking interactive and
expressibility capabilities
and as a result what has happened is
there is this discordance between what
these models can do and what is expected
of them by patients and you know care
providers and others and this in turn
has I think prevented broad uptake of
medical AI
um
and you can see that for example we
don't really have ai in many clinics out
there like helping us with diagnosis and
so on and so forth
but the recent progress with you know
Transformer based large language models
it offers us an opportunity to change
all of this and redesign and rethink
medical AI systems with language at the
heart of it uh mediating human AI
interactions between doctors researchers
and patients
and I will be honest if I don't point
out that there has been a large volume
of work in this space particularly in
the last few years there have been
various attempts to train language
models in the biomedical domain
with models of various different sizes
on different corpuses of biomedical data
uh and while this is exciting uh the
quality bar for applications in the
medical domain is actually quite High
uh and so what is missing is actually is
that there is actually not many good
evaluation benchmarks and evaluation
protocols and Frameworks so we don't
have the equivalent of a big bench in
medicine
um and hopefully you guys have covered
big bench before
um and so big benches is Benchmark where
uh you can access large language models
across a variety of task domains and
settings and but we don't have an
equivalent of that in the medical domain
um and further if you look at the
evaluations that are typically used in
these previous studies uh they only look
at objective metrics like accuracy or
you know natural language generation
metrics like blue or cider but these
fail to capture the nuances of real
world use cases in clinical settings
so what we essentially need was uh you
know a good Benchmark uh and a task and
also a good evaluation framework for
evaluating these models
and so to address this unmet need and
assess the potential of llms in medicine
uh in our team we decided to focus on
the medical question answering task uh
why uh because answering medical
questions is actually quite challenging
it requires reading comprehension skills
uh ability to accurately recall medical
knowledge and also manipulate and reason
about it
and furthermore the Q a task is
generally enough and can subsume a bunch
of different application settings such
as summarization of clinical notes uh
clinical decision decision support and
also uh like Primary Care triaging
operation concerns and so on
um so we've identified the task uh the
next question is what data said and so
when we looked at the literature over
here what we saw is that there were
several data sets floating around
assessing model capabilities in a bunch
of different settings
um so what we decided was we should
probably just unify all of them and put
together in one Benchmark and so we did
that and we called it multimet QA and so
if you look at it this Benchmark now
covers medical question answering data
sets from a bunch of different settings
such as you know professional medical
questions uh like the US medical license
exam style questions uh it also includes
medical research questions those based
on PubMed abstracts and so on and also
questions from live live users and
consumers uh asking about medical
information
and also the setting changes it could be
closed domain or open domain and the
model may be expected to produce long
form answer in one setting and maybe a
short form answer in another setting
um and finally we saw that uh while the
the
q a data sets which covered consumer
yeah
uh I'll come back to this okay
um so yeah very quickly uh finally when
we looked
um
okay cool
um so the question was how do we
evaluate long-form answers and uh I'll
come back to this a bit later
um and so very quickly uh when we looked
at the data sets that uh actually uh
provided consumer medical questions we
found them to be quite small in size so
we decided to augment them and so we
went out to Google and looked at like
the most frequently Asked consumer
medical questions and so we curated a
data set and we added that to The
Benchmark and we call that a health
search query over here
and so yeah again uh how big is the
composite
uh I'll come back later I'm sure
um so here are a few examples uh so if
you look at the consumer medical
questions they are quite short in nature
um while and so they come from the
health search queue and the live QA data
sets whereas I think if you look at the
USMLE style questions these are like
long Vineyards and so doctors have to
like really really carefully read
through them and come up with the right
answer which often involves the process
of elimination so again very very
different application settings and uh so
the model has to really like um really
adapt and understand it has to do well
in all these settings across the board
um and live QA is interesting because
the answers the reference answers over
here were actually provided by
Librarians so that's another good
comparison point for us going ahead
and so in terms of statistics we had a
total of seven uh data sets in this
Benchmark uh as I said we cover
professional medicine medical research
and consumer medical questions uh
they're again of various different sizes
um and can be long-form short form open
domain and close domain so very diverse
and I think it provides a very
comprehensive evaluation of models in
this medical question answering setting
um so we have a task on The Benchmark uh
the next question again I think I asked
was how do we evaluate these models and
as I mentioned before automatic
automated metrics are actually deeply
unsatisfactory because they fail to
capture the nuances of real world
clinical applications so what we did was
uh actually heavily inspired by some of
students work over here was to put
together a human evaluation framework
for assessing these long-form answers uh
and uh
this had two parts the first part was
evaluation by clinicians and we asked
them to rate the model responses along
12 axes pertaining to factuality of the
responses uh ability to recall uh
medical knowledge to Medical reasoning
and also for the potential of harm and
bias in these responses
um but if you look at like the potential
end users of such Medical qna Systems
these are likely going to be non-expert
layer users so it is also important to
get these uh answers evaluated by them
as well and so we uh also additionally
asked a pool of layer users as to how
helpful and actionable they thought the
answers were
um and so that was our evaluation
framework uh and we also have the
Benchmark effects so now we've moved on
to the fun part of you know building and
aligning llms to the medical domain task
um so in this work we decided to build
on the palm family of language models uh
has that been covered in the course
before okay great uh so but very quickly
uh I believe this is still the largest
publicly announced uh you know densely
activated decoder only large language
model uh with the largest one being 5
and 40 billion parameters in total
um a few more details the models trained
on uh sand a 40 billion tokens uh 25 of
which is multilingual uh the data come
from a bunch of different sources
including uh social media conversations
web pages books GitHub and Wikipedia and
so on and so forth
um and at this time of release the model
was share the art on many NLP reasoning
benchmarks and also was the first Model
to exceed uh the average human
performance on big bench uh further over
the last year
um Palm derived models were shown to be
super useful in a bunch of different
application settings including for code
generation which was the Palm coder
model in robotics the Palm secan model
and also for answering math and science
questions uh which is the minervous
models and so we thought Palm was a very
good foundation model for us to build on
and use it in the medical domain as well
and overall I think Palm is a true magic
of engineering but I will refer you all
back to akancha's uh paper on this for
uh more details I think it's a must read
and again in late October last year
Jason way and a few others at Google
brain came out with the flan Palm
variant of these uh of the farm model
and this is basically the instruction
tune counterpart and this model was even
better than palm and I believe this is
still the soda state of the art on many
benchmarks such as mmlu tidy QA and I
think it exceeds Palm performance by an
average of 9.4 percent across big bench
tasks
so so we decided to build on the plan
bomb model and we applied a combination
of prompting strategies including few
shot prompting
um Chain of Thought reasoning and also
self-consistency to the 540 billion
parameter variant and we evaluated it on
the multimed QA data sets that had the
short form McQ questions
and we found that this model was really
really good
um at the time of publication this model
on the USM limited data set exceeded the
previous state of the art by over 17
percent
it's only for the USMLE material data
sets that's right
um and so you see that the accuracy over
the previous state of the art at the
time of publication went up by over 17
and I believe this was the first paralym
based AI system to obtain like a passing
equal in score which was 60 or above on
this benchmark
um and similarly when we looked at other
McQ data sets in The Benchmark for
example mcmcqa which is a data set of
Indian medical entrance examination
questions the model was again the state
of the art on PubMed care which was
question answering based on PubMed
abstracts that was again the model was
straight of the art at the time of
publication uh and same story on mmlu
clinical topics as well which include
genetics uh Anatomy professional
medicine clinical knowledge and a bunch
of other topics in there
um so
all this was great and then when we
started looking at the scaling plots uh
what we again saw was that the
performance seemed to be improving as we
scaled the model uh from uh 8 billion to
62 billion to 540 billion and so what
this basically suggested that these
general purpose large language models
trained on public Internet seem to
encode clinical knowledge pretty well uh
and they uh and their medical reasoning
abilities tend to scale with model
parameter size
uh we also did another experiment when
we looked at selective prediction uh and
we used the self-consistency uh votes to
determine when to differ and this is
important in clinical settings uh
because you know doctors uh communicate
when they don't know about something and
if our AI systems are going to be used
in clinical settings for example for
diagnosis they should be able to tell
you when they don't know something
and so what we observed here was this
fairly crude metric uh we were getting
like a linear Improvement in performance
as being changed the default threshold
uh and this was quite nice but in
practice is actually quite inefficient
because you're generating like you know
multiple uh decoding samples to be able
to compute this metric so we need a
better method there was an important
model asks uh yeah it's basically says
I'm uncertain around one and that's uh
determined based on the cell consistency
votes I see okay so you don't have
certificate
exactly exactly
no because they just trained on this
next word prediction task and that
depends on the data set the PubMed QA
has some answers which are maybe but
again we don't explicitly fine tune the
models over here so you know the models
are not trained
involved
so we went out and then basically
after this
oh no so this is primarily based on the
reference of uh in the data sets which
is so this is all accuracy Matrix so we
already know between the four options of
five options which one's the right one
and so we just do the classification
yeah so I'll come back to the clinician
evaluation a bit later
sorry maybe I missed something how are
you measuring uncertain tool
um so if you know what self-consistency
prompting what we do is we generate
multiple decodes from the same model and
then we see uh the number of times uh
the highest ranking answer is voted and
based on that you can fix a threshold
and say if it's below this number I'm
going to differ so if say the majority
answer comes up in your self-consistency
equals only like 10 times out of K or
whatever uh then and that if if that n
is too small then it's very likely the
model is uncertain so that's how we
differ
um
um so they don't really see like a paper
off in the spot so like it's not the
best but the rest would look like
um I think if you plot it further to
Flatline uh but again that's not useful
I mean if you're saying no to every
question that's not useful at all so you
want to have a reasonable definite
percentage
right I think that's high
I think that's still higher 50 is quite
high but again that this is a very
contrived setting but in real world use
cases probably I think that number
should be much lower
yeah
because
of course yeah
that's right I think balanced accuracy
might be a better metric but we looked
at some of these data sets and uh one
data set this queue was pretty bad the
pubmedia data set and I think no one
should use it so if anyone's reporting
soda numbers on that data set you should
just discuss them and talking about very
specific people
um but um again um I think as I
mentioned these accuracy metrics are
good for you know publicity and pushing
up Benchmark numbers and so on and so
forth but the real evaluation is human
evaluation of the long form answers and
that's what I'll come to in the next
part
um
um so so far so good right um I mean we
were getting uh sold our results on
these benchmarks and we're very happy
and so what we did was I mean one thing
you'll observe that I have so far only
reported results on multiple choice
questions short form answers uh so what
was left for us to do was to take these
answers uh take these models and
generate long-form answers to the other
uh data sets that we had and get them
human evaluated and I think that is
where the real project began uh when we
looked at the uh evolves uh by you know
experts and lay people it revealed very
like key gaps and limitations uh in the
flan Farm responses uh we were often
seeing that these models are
hallucinating or you know producing
incomplete responses and when we asked
experts like whether they preferred
clinician generated answers or these
model generated answers they almost
always preferred clinician generated
answers
um
so it was very clear that's
really what that means it's evaluators
are these people or these okay
um and so what this previous results
showed was while these models already
encode some degree of uh you know
clinical knowledge to be really used in
actual real world settings you need to
align these models better to safety
critical requirements of the medical
domain
um but a big challenge is we did not
have any kind of supervised or feedback
data and so we really need the alignment
technique to be data efficient
um but thankfully uh we had instruction
from tuning uh which was uh introduced
by Brian Lester and a few others at
Google a couple of years back and how
this method works is uh it essentially
freezes the big llm model and only
learns an additional small set of prompt
vectors uh which can then be used to
condition the model that inference uh
when doing the generation and the nice
thing about this is it allows very
easier use of the model across tasks and
domains and you only need to like carry
around this additional prompt parameters
right and these tend to be much smaller
than like the fan the billions of
parameters that you have in the yellow
um and the other good thing is this is
very computationally efficient as well
so like if you were to do end-to-end
fine tuning uh often in all compute
infrastructure
um even with like a few thousand
examples that would take like a few days
whereas with instruction pump tuning uh
a given the data set size is also
reduced the number of examples that you
need is quite small uh and be you're
just updating the prompt token vectors
uh it meant that we were able to like
get model updates in like a few hours
and so that was like really fast and
enabled like really quick iterations for
us
um so this was how we put together the
final metform model uh we say go ahead
sorry
okay cool
um so this was how we put together the
final metform model um so we used
instructions and exam plus from a panel
of uh expert clinicians and these were
uh in the order of hundreds not like the
Thousand certain tens of thousands and
you see a few examples over there
there's an instruction uh followed by
model answer followed by an explanation
and we use that to learn the prompt
vectors and so the final metform model
is basically uh all of plan bomb plus
these additional soft prompt Vector uh
parameters uh which are used to align
the model to the requirements of the
medical domain and why this works well
is because as we have seen before the
model already has medical knowledge
encoded in it all we need is to like
teach the model how to use it properly
in the given application setting and
that's what these prompt uh parameters
do for us
so the question I wanted to ask is um
navigate to be published a lot about
like borrowing chat and given the fact
that you have all of these student
preferences it's best by your evaluators
and you guys explain and you guys can
find that a reward or preference model
yeah I think you can think about like
different stages of model development
right so this is pre-deployment and
release in the real world so you can't
put a crappy model out there in the real
world so even before doing that if you
can like get like maybe 100 examples
from whatever experts that you can get
hold of and use that to prompt your new
model that's better that's a much better
starting point uh before you expose them
all to the real world and collect
preferences from real users at scale and
so I think rlhf is also uh much less
sample efficient uh compared to
instruction from tuning uh again because
you're probably trying to update uh the
uh your entire model as well so I think
this is a very good starting point and
so they kind of will be combined
depending on how uh depending on the
life cycle of the model evaluations
the data set is public we have we I'll
talk about the results uh in a bit sorry
about the human evaluations contained
publicly within the Asm
uh you mean the model responses and what
the human celebrations oh that's a good
point Beyond so far not considering
releasing them but maybe we can perfect
okay uh do you see a use case for that
well just uh
you have a bunch of data in the bar and
says
[Music]
so if I wanted to train a reward model
that data is what I would explain that
yeah that's a good point I think the
evaluation data set is I'll talk about
this a bit it's still small but I think
if we scale it up and we are doing it
right now I think we can release that
and that will be I think the good
resource of what you're trying to do
cool
um so we have them at one model as I
said and now we took the long form
answers from it and compared that to the
flat bomb model as well as to answer
generate by expectations and as I said
we have two parts to the human
evaluation one is by expert clinicians
and the other one is by layer users and
so what do these results look like uh on
the wire and for your questions that we
got these evaluation results on uh what
we observed typically
across the board was
um when we looked at like different axes
while the flan Palm model would be quite
terrible honestly uh the Metro model
would do much better and typically close
the gap to expert clinicians so on this
access you see that like the platform
model has probably a 60 odd accuracy
accuracy in terms of like scientific
consensus
um the metform model improves them
improves on that quite a bit and closes
the capital Dimensions over here
uh similar story on other axes as well
over here you see uh the the like
clinicians rating on the axis of uh how
how well the model can retrieve medical
knowledge how well it can reason about
it
um and again we see the same Trend as in
the previous slide
no so what can be present at the same
time so you can have evidence of correct
comprehension also evidence of incorrect
comprehension uh sometimes
exactly so so that's why they're not one
minus over here but the trends are the
same oh so that's why I skipped a lot
but that's a detail a good point
um yeah again so there's a type over
here uh but this one pertains to
incorrect our missing content
um but this was an interesting one
because what when we were doing this
from tuning thing uh was
um we were teaching the metform model to
produce uh longer and more complete
answers and so you can see a few
qualitative examples later but what
ended up happening in the process was
sometimes the model was maybe producing
uh more incorrect information so that's
why you see that maybe in this
particular axis uh the flan model was
slightly better but again this was much
worse compared to uh clinicians
foreign
um it's a good question it is more like
it's something something completely out
of context uh so it may be irrelevant to
the question
so that's what I would say so
um we also looked at like possible and
extent and likelihood of harm uh and
again we see that with the instruction
from training we're able to close the
gap to expect Generations over here uh
same on the bias access as well
okay sure
have you interpret the top
uh exactly so like I
I basically see like something death and
then the clinicians at like six percent
seems like
um
yeah so it's basically so there might be
certain conditions or pathologies or
diagnosis right like cancer uh and uh if
for example recognition has not got that
or has maybe given a response that does
not appropriately convey the severity of
the condition then that could
potentially lead to severe harm or death
and so that's what we were trying to
capture over here
um so that's a very high level overview
this is a
uh I think of any nuanced topic and
there's a framework for it called the AI
ahrq framework and so we've linked that
in the paper as well and so I think that
gives you a very detailed notion of harm
and bias that's why I would refer to
that but at a high level this is what
I'm talking about hope that helps all
right so when later I read class and I
say the clinician had 5.7 or external
possible arm which means like what would
I say does that mean that like they
recommend something like
maybe they fail to recommend something
uh yeah
um so it's basically a misdiagnosis or
maybe failing to capture the severity of
a diagnosis this is typical in life
threatening conditions right so
so it's more often than not not mistakes
but rather just missing out on details
um yeah so I talked about bias as well
um and then as I said the other axis of
human evaluation was with layer users uh
and so we asked them how well does the
model answer uh address the intent of
the question and again we saw with
instruction from during metform closing
the Gap to clinicians and then we asked
them like how helpful the responses were
and what we see is that while flan Palm
responses were considered to be helpful
like 60 of the time the number improved
to 80 for metform but it was still
fairly lower compared to clinicians at
90 percent
um
so here are a few qualitative examples
and so what you see is that Physicians
and this is typically because they work
in time constraint settings they are
their answers tend to be precise uh and
sucking uh succinct uh but sometimes
it's very hard as layer users or
patients to like decifer and decode the
answer and get all the full set of
details right and so what I think
language models like metform can help
with is actually converting The
Physician speed to something that's more
easily digestible by layer users and so
this is where I think uh how these
models will likely fit in uh in clinical
settings in the real term where they're
going to augment physicians in terms of
like Contracting with patients and other
Physicians and researchers as well
very
if I predict as a patients
that's right I think it's subjective and
so that's why I think we're still seeing
like um layer users platform answers to
be helpful 80 well that's much higher
for Physicians
um so it's not perfect by any means but
I think this is where it's there is a
complementality element we feel over
here
and we've asked students like when we
ask people like uh how easy is it to
like interpret doctor uh notes uh or
recommendations and they often say oh
it's very hard I need to go back to
Google search for what these terms mean
what these abbreviations mean and so I
think this is where language model can
come and take that note and convert that
into something that's more easily
digestible uh like
um so I think that's the opportunity
over here I feel
um so that was all on our paper but I
also want to maybe very quickly point
out a very recent work which came out
last week with this rather provocative
title uh do we still need clinical
language models and by clinical language
models they meant smaller models which
are trained in domain with clinical data
such as medical nodes
and records and so on and so forth and
what this paper basically suggests is
that smaller fine-tuned in-domain LMS
are likely better than general purpose
llms in this paper I think they
evaluated on gpd3 uh with in context
learning
um so I think that's a pretty
interesting and neat observation I think
there's a lot of value for a smaller in
domain LMS such as PubMed GPT and a few
other variants but I think one thing
that this paper does not do is consider
in context learning uh sorry prompt
tuning and I think that's where some of
the benefits of this larger general
purpose llms shine and again we haven't
done any uh in domain LM free training
on the this large general purpose
models but that's again an option for us
as well to do it on the line so you can
take these 540 billion parameters and
then still train it on medical nodes or
whatever domain specific data that you
can get hold of and hopefully they'll
probably further improve the performance
um so key takeaways so far um what I
want to convey was general purpose llms
it looks like they do encode medical
knowledge and performance on medical
reasoning tasks seem to improve at scale
however these models I don't think can
be directly used out of the box in
clinical settings and they need to be
aligned with the safety critical
requirements of the medical domain and I
think instruction prompting prompting is
an extremely efficient technique both on
the data side and also on the compute
side and we should probably use it more
often depending on and hopefully the API
starts supporting it as well
um and these models appear to be closing
the Gap to expert clinicians uh at least
on this medical question answering tasks
and while this is hugely exciting and
has profound implications you can all
probably dream up and imagine the
application scenarios over here uh I
think comprehensive benchmarks and
evaluation Frameworks are necessary in
order to further assess and improve
these models for available use cases
um so I'll stop over here any questions
a lot of it is because these data sets
tend to get locked in silos with privacy
and other kinds of regulations which
prevent them from being put out there in
the real world so you have to have like
hip-hop compliant systems for storage
and so on and so forth so it's very
difficult to get data out of these silos
and put together an open Benchmark
um so honestly I feel like that's
probably not going to improve the the
scale of these data sets at least the
open version of these data sets are
going to remain uh quite small compared
to the big LM training data sets or the
computer division data sets on natural
images and so on and so forth but what
may happen in the future is we may have
like more distributed Federated
evaluation settings where you take the
model into
these uh private silos and get them
evaluated on so they are never exposed
and put out there in the public but
rather we can have these very dead
evaluation settings
um so I think that there's some work on
that already there's a system called
metforf and you'll probably see more of
them foreign
sure so the question over here was why
medical data sets are smaller compared
to uh natural image data sets in
computer vision or LM training data sets
and so on and so forth
what do you think are some of the
earliest applications of medical llms
like deployed in Industry
uh I think the first set of use cases
are probably going to be not Diagnostic
in it sorry the question was uh what do
you think are the use cases of medical
llms and medical industry settings and
so
the answer is I think the first set of
use cases that we are going to see are
probably going to be non-diagnostic in
nature but more around like if you uh if
a patient comes in and interacts with a
doctor can you like generate summary
notes uh and can you do like workflow
tasks such as generating letters for
insurance for medications for referrals
and so on and so forth I think these
tasks are right up the alley of large
language models and I think if not
already in the next six months to a year
we'll see a lot of these use cases
coming up and I think that's going to
you know make doctors like care
providers life much easier because right
now they're spending a lot of time doing
these things and not actually providing
care and attending to the patient
diagnostic use cases I think will take a
lot more time we need a lot more
evaluation the data sets as we can see
are probably not there the evaluation
Frameworks are not there but I think in
the long run and that is the dream
setting right
and then maybe a problem is men I'm
assuming Ned Palm is not open source
what do you think the best open source
model is automatically
um you know I think it depends on the so
the question is what is the best uh open
source uh model for medical data uh it I
think depends on the evaluation setting
uh so uh I think the PubMed GPT model
from the Stanford Foundation models
group is quite strong uh I think gpt3 or
3.5 or whatever variant if you can bring
in some domain specific medical data and
do some in tuning adding that model can
also improve quite a bit so I think
those two would be my favorite starting
points over here
it's you can just think them as vectors
corresponding to a few additional tokens
uh so it's not really uh human legible
so the question was what do the stock
prom factors look like uh and are they
human legible and uh yeah the answer is
no they're not
um
sure uh so the question was uh given uh
a lot of the hospital systems and
providers networks are quite low-tech
and don't have good enough Hardware do
you really think Federal learning could
be used for distributed training of
large-scale llms
um I think we are increasingly seeing a
trend towards cloud and so a lot of
these uh Hospital systems are moving
their storage and data and compute to
standard Cloud providers like AWS or
Azure or Google cloud and so I think
that helps because these systems on the
backend side do have the compute to be
able to like train these kind of models
um I think it's going to be a very
gradual process so systems that have
high quality infrastructure probably
we're going to start with that first and
then gradually work our way into the
long tail uh but it also feels like
something that will inevitably exist in
the world uh so 10 years down the line
or 15 years down the line when we have
these distributed large-scale llm
Training Systems uh we'll always think
back oh why did I even doubt that this
will not exist it's so obvious it's
something that has to exist because
that's where all the patient data is all
the interesting data is right so I think
that'll just happen it's just not clear
where that's going to be done by one
company whether that's going to be done
by Consortium of academic uh or industry
groups or where governments are going to
be involved or so on and so forth so
that's right uh so the question over
here is we're seeing uh cloud computing
but we are pretty much uploading the
data to the same warehouse uh the answer
is true but again I think these are all
going to be separate buckets with their
own access controls and so on and so
forth so that is how you can
differentiate between them
uh
there's not a lot of fun videos
sure so the question was has there been
any studies in metform looking at
private information in these data sets
and the short answer is no uh the one of
the criteria for selecting the data sets
that we used in the study was to not
include any kind of personally
identifiable data or clinical data of
that sort and that helped like you know
get this paper out on time but I think
that's an important Point uh
it's unlikely that we're going to have a
lot of Phi data in public well uh in the
public uh data sets that we are training
on uh but uh even when you're training
on say one private Corpus and then
you're using it in another application
setting uh you want to ensure that the
model does not leak out any kind of Phi
information uh during this generation so
I think those sort of studies are
necessary we haven't gotten to them yet
um
uh so the question is what are the next
steps in terms of improving these models
further uh yeah retrieval is a very
important one being able to site sources
and especially take in authoritative
sources and use that in generating the
answers and also communicating that to
the users is very important I think how
you can communicate uncertainty is very
important so we've gotten to some extent
using instructional prompt tuning but I
think that can be much much better
um so I think that's another big bucket
uh again I would stress on the
evaluation side like you know looking at
more data sets which for example may do
a q a on health records or or other
kinds of medical data I think that will
be important and also extending the
evaluation both in terms of scale uh
having a diverse panel of clinician
support and also in terms of the data
that you're using maybe I adversarily
modifying the questions to include like
demographic confounders or something
like that I think those are all could be
interesting directions
um I think on the modeling side the
interesting question for me is again
this interplay between smaller uh
domain specific elements versus large
general purpose elements and how that's
going to play out
there seems to be some evidence of
emergence over here uh with especially
with medical reasoning and so as you can
see at lower scale sometimes the
performance is not good enough I mean 50
I mean that's a good number but that's
just not viable and but when you get to
like 80 90 products really become useful
right and so that we are seeing at like
you know bigger parameter sizes of these
models but I I don't know I think it's
still an open question over here
yeah
this the question was is hallucination
an issue I think it still is but I
believe that you can control that fairly
well with instruction prompt tuning but
like any kind of feedback data I think
it's not terribly difficult to do and so
the the
uh I think it the it might have been
overblown generally so especially when
you are doing it in a particular domain
I think it's easier to control foreign
hallucinations and general purpose LMS
uh and this in this particular
application domain it seems particularly
relevant and so can you expand on that a
little bit further
um sure so
what we are seeing is even with like an
order of a few hundred examples from
expert clinicians uh teaching the models
how to communicate medical information
uh
that is good enough to get the model to
maybe stop hallucinating or at least
communicate its uncertainty in a better
way uh so this at least in this
particular domain or this setting it
feels more tractable to us and the
reason I'm saying this is we've looked
at the answers qualitatively and we are
seeing that the model does not tend to
like generate like super long answers uh
or you know uh or like you know make
like very confident predictions but
rather the tone itself becomes like uh
very reserved uh and it starts using
terms like
um you know maybe this needs to be done
further or something like that which
communicates uncertainty uh so how well
is that actually correlated with the
representation underlying uncertainty
that we have is still I think an area of
research but I think this is already
promising for us that it feels
controllable in limited application
settings like medicine
but if you have a general purpose llm
trying to answer pretty much everything
about the world I think that's a much
harder problem
um do you think that would be a feature
of what's the domain David says like in
medical situations doctors or reserved
for apps and don't absolutely have
absolutions
specialize right like it could be
something else entirely also I'm just
curious
yeah so the question is do you think uh
this uh the way how the model is
performing in this domain is that a
feature of the data sets in the medical
domain and
typically based on how doctors
communicate and I think that's true uh
and I think that's something we need to
build on and use over here and I think
that's extremely helpful and hopefully
this kind of behavior is General enough
and can be transmitted to the model even
when it's used in non-medical settings
to be like you know uh more reserved
when it's communicating uh you know
hallucinate less and so on and so forth
so I believe that that's one of the
opportunities over here to like use
these benchmarks uh come up with methods
that you know reduce hallucination uh
communicate uncertainty better and then
use that as a bi-directional learning
opportunity to improve the general
purpose level
um so if you have any further questions
I'll come back again at the end of the
talk but I want to cover the rest of the
applications as well
uh so the next domain I want to talk
about is proteins uh
um and the papers from now I'm going to
like you know zip through them a little
bit give in time
but the first one I want to talk is this
paper from a few Folks at Google
research back in 2020 called Master
language modeling for proteins by uh
linearly scalable long context
Transformers
um so the problem here is that modeling
long-range biological sequences uh
requires efficient Transformer
architectures
um and so in this particular paper what
they introduced was this performer
architecture uh which approximates the
softmax attention kernel via low rank
decomposition uh and so this does not
incorporate any sparsity price uh say
like other methods like uh the reformer
or there are many others and and this is
good because uh sparsity press may not
be appropriate for uh you know
biological data such as protein which
require Global interactions to be
modeled
and then the other thing is this uh
model uh the performance scales linearly
rather than quadratically with the
sequence linked L and the number of
random features that you need to
approximate this soft Max attention
kernel uh m is completely independent of
the input sequence link
so just to very quickly visualize the
speedups and the space complexity
improvements what you're having with
this low rank decomposition is instead
of having like fat matrices in your soft
Max attention kernel you now have
thinner mattresses which are determined
by the size of the random features M and
that basically reduces your quadratic
complexity to something that is more
linear in nature and also leads to space
improvements
um so I would yeah there are more
theoretical analysis and details in the
paper and I would refer you all back to
it uh but what we see in terms of
results when doing protein language
modeling uh is that uh the accuracy of
this of this model is on par with
Transformers uh while reducing
computational costs quite a bit and so
what this suggests is that the
approximation of the soft Max attention
kernel is a tight approximation so that
is good uh and then when you compare
that with other methods such as the
reformer or the lymphomer the accuracy
is much higher at least on this task so
it seems that compared to other methods
that approximate uh like try to build
more efficient uh Transformers this one
is much better for biological sequence
data at least in this setting
and finally if you look at the attention
uh uh
um uh attention of the amino acid
similarity Matrix
you can see that the performer model
recognizes highly similar uh amino acid
pairs such as DNA and fny over here so
that suggests that the model is learning
the right set of information that we
really want over here
so that was a two-minute overview of
that paper uh but uh I wonder yeah and
talk about another one which also I
think is really cool
um
so this one is uh called protein LM
Again by a few other folks at Google
research and what this does is uh model
based uh natural language protein
annotation
and why this problem is important is
because the protein information is in
very high demand uh so over 50 of all
known proteins that have been sequenced
we don't actually know what they do so
it's important that we're able to like
decipher that to some degree at least
and then the second thing is we may want
to for example find protein sequences
with given functions and this is
particularly important in the crisprit I
mean and so if you can train
bi-directional models that can do this
um I think that'll be incredibly helpful
and
and the reason I say this again is that
uh that the unipro database that has
over uh uh that is I think millions of
researchers worldwide using it today and
so getting this information populated in
that database would be incredibly uh
useful and accelerate a lot of research
in the space
and so the European bioinformatics
Institute they have curated this free
text data about proteins uh and so
basically you can use this protein
record to like train these models and so
what you want to do is you want to maybe
learn to directly map from amino acid
sequences to natural language
descriptions of them uh and this problem
is not too different from an image
captioning problem where instead of
having a sequence of pixels
um I don't know if sequence is right but
again if you have pixels uh instead you
have a sequence of Harmon assets and
they can range a number from you know 2
to 40K and then what you want to
generate out is a protein uh description
of the protein
and in this paper the way they do this
is they train a T5 model on protein
sequence annotation tests so the the
tasks are set up in a bunch of different
ways and the supervised data comes from
a bunch of different sources in the
protein record that they have and this
model is an encoded equal to T5 model
um so it's a very cool application and
the results are that out of the 56
million proteins in that uniprot
database that were previously
uncharacterized uh 49 million of them
now have Associated textual descriptions
so we now have a handle on what they do
um
and so that's really cool and then the
other one I think which is probably even
more interesting is now you can run
queries like find me a smaller version
of this crispr cas9 protein so that it
can Target certain tissues better and
now the model can you know come back
with sequences and so I think this is
again going to be incredibly useful and
um you want to accelerate a lot of
research in this space already there's a
lot of momentum I think these models are
going to further help
uh
so that was on proteins the last class
of applications that I want to cover is
on the genomics side
um again the first paper over here uh
was uh some work last year from our
geometry at Google uh which is building
Gap aware sequence Transformers for
sequence correction
so this model is called Deep consensus
and so what role does this model play
and why does it matter
so if you look at the sequencing data
life cycle what you do is you go from
basically atoms to bits and so you have
this physical specimen which hopefully
has some DNA in it and you
put it through a sequencing machine such
as black bio and that comes out with the
raw data and that raw data gets mapped
to a reference genome uh and then
sometimes there might be diffs between
an individual and the reference genome
and that can be corrected through this
model called Deep variant that was
introduced by our team a few years back
and that's open source and then once you
have this uh sequence you can then use
it for a bunch of different analysis
such as uh you know ancestry or like
just you know basic biomedical research
uh so where deep variant fits in is it
actually makes the raw DNA reach that
comes out from the back biosequencer uh
it tries to make it more accurate uh and
uh so how the bio sequencer actually
works is it uses this circular uh
consensus sequencing algorithm where the
DNA molecule is like you know red
several times and it produces multiple
different sub reads and these subreits
are
they do contain some errors and so
they're finally like assembled together
and so what deep variant tries to do is
it tries to improve on the errors over
here basically that comes out from just
this circular consensus sequencing
algorithm
and so how does this model work uh as I
said the basic task for deep consensus
is to use the cacs data and the sub
reads associated with them to generate a
corrected sequence and so in this
example when we run through the model
what we see is that while the CCS
identity was at like 95.7 The Deep
consensus prediction identity was at 100
so it's a fairly simple task where
you're trying to like reduce errors that
come out from the back bio with the CCS
algorithm
and so the very natural question is
where do these labels come from
um so each CCS sequence that you have
that is aligned to a high quality
assembly uh and this high quality
assembly is created by having many CCs
uh reads uh stitched together and so
that ends up having fewer errors and so
you can then try to use that high
quality stitched assembly and map that
back to the CCA trade for a given block
and use that as that label so uh that
results in more you know like stronger
ground truth and you can use that to
train the model to improve the accuracy
further and so this is what the model is
trained on and so the model looks like
this it's a Transformer architecture uh
it takes these sub reads and this uh CCS
read as well and it has a bunch of
additional context features that come in
from this uh the sequencer itself the
instrument sequencing instrument as well
um and these are all fed into the
Transformer model uh it produces a
Polish segment and these segments are
then like just together to produce the
final polished read over here
uh one thing I will point out over here
is that in order to train this model you
can't use a cross entropy loss and this
is because uh
you know if you insert you often have
insertions in DNA sequences and so that
can when you use a cross entropy loss
like really throw off the model even
like a single error as you can see over
here can propagate throughout the
sequence and make it really worse so
what you need is a special kind of
alignment Clause based on a distance uh
that can really capture this error much
much better
and so making this alignment loss work
on you know tpus and making it
differentiable is I think the real meat
of this paper and so again go back to
the paper if you're interested in that
kind of topic I think that's really cool
um but at a very high level uh how well
does this model work so if you look at
the final output you have the read name
you have the base predictions and also
the predicted quality which can be
thought of as a confidence score and
these base predictions are often quite
long and so you can see that continuous
off screen because it's like you know
10K electronic bases long over here and
when you look at the Quality it improved
quite a bit over the vanilla CCS
algorithm over here the per read
accuracy over here improves quite a bit
uh and so you may ask like what is the
real world impact of this kind of model
right uh so the answer is this model is
already being used in the real world so
at Stanford in the genomics team by Dr
Ashley and a few others there was this
recent uh Ultra rapid nanopore genome
sequencing paper where they set a world
record for the fastest genome sequencing
and this deep consensus Transformer
architecture was used in that assembly
sequence and so in this particular study
they were able to very quickly diagnose
that Matthew over here had a heart
condition due to genetic reasons and so
they were very quickly able to like put
Matthew on the patient's bonus list over
here so that's the kind of real world
impact you can have with these
biomedical transform models and AI
systems in general
and uh very quickly the last uh paper
that I want to talk about is this paper
from deepmind on effective gene
expression prediction from sequences by
integrating long-range interactions this
was published in nature methods
and the motivation for this work is
again that since the Human Genome
Project there have been thousands of
genome-wide Association study hits where
the goal is to you know map uh genetic
variants to different kind of disease
phenotypes but a lot of this involves
experimentation and experimentation like
real world experimentation takes a lot
of time and so if you can like do that
with machine learning models that's
really really great and so that's what
they're set up to do in this scraper and
so if you look at the gene itself there
are like you know 10 of the gene are
going to be like coding variants and
these influence protein function uh and
then the way they can cause diseases is
by disrupting the structure of proteins
that are generated or by affecting the
protein protein interactions uh the good
part about these coding variants are
they tend to be closer to the Gene and
so they're easier to interpret uh on the
other hand the the 90 of the gene is
like non-coding variants and the way
they work is they influence protein
expression so they are more like
regulatory uh sequences
um and so the way they can lead to
diseases if they have any variance is by
this disrupting the transcription uh of
proteins
and given that these non-coding variants
can be very very far away from the Gene
and the coding variants it's very
difficult to interpret them and so the
question is can we train transfer models
that can predict uh the influence of
these non-coding variants and so that is
the task over here and so this is a
visualization again
um so the paper again looks at uh the
the it focuses on transcription which is
the first step in terms of converting
DNA into RNA and the way this is done is
you have a RNA polymerase which gets
recruited uh at the beginning of the
gene by these proteins called
transcription factors and these
transcription factors have a binding
side which correspond to these promoters
which are quite close to the gene but
then you also have these enhancers which
can be like very very far away from
these promoters uh in terms of the
linear space uh also influencing this
transcription uh and you may ask how can
such uh
how can these enhancers influence the
activity over here this is because while
they may be far away in the linear space
when the the sequence folds and in the
3D structure they will end up being
quite close to each other and so that
they can completely affect the
transcription process over here
so it's a very high level overview of
what's happening over here and in terms
of the biology uh and so the question is
if there are any variants in these
non-coding variants
um and uh in these enhances uh they may
like disrupt the transcription Factor
binding and this can in turn lead to
like you know proteins and then finally
to diseases right so we want to be able
to predict that based on the DNA
sequences that have been generated
so the problem is kind of quite
straightforward it's a supervised
learning problem uh the the setup is
predict experimental data from these
gnac sequences and this can take many
different forms the primary one is gene
expression over here but then there are
also other tasks such as DNA
accessibility uh histone modifications
and transcription effect and binding and
so on and so forth
um so as you can imagine the Baseline
model for this task uh for many years
was the CNN model and as you stacked up
a little you know differential layers
you can increase the receptive field but
there's a limit to that
um so in this work what they showed was
uh you can use Transformers instead and
do better modeling of these long-range
interactions uh so the final model is
called and former which is a combination
of this enhancer and Transformer and so
if you look at the model itself it has a
few CNN layers at the beginning but then
it has a bunch of Transformer blocks
that are stacked together
um and the input is uh you know 200 KV
DNA sequences uh and there are
approximately 30 examples that have been
trained and the output is like genomic
tracks of this RNA expression with and
they have organism specific head so one
for humans and one for uh Mouse
um and finally one key detail is that
relative position encodings that were
used in this model were actually very
key and these relative position
encodings for modeling this power law of
interactions uh and as a result of you
know using this related position
encodings with the Transformer block
architecture they were now able to model
like interactions over 100 K base pairs
away
and so you see that in the results over
here uh so you have the experimental
data in green and you can see the CNN
Baseline over here and you see that as
soon as you go far away
um uh you see that like the more the CN
model is no longer like able to like
capture these Gene Expressions uh but
you can see that the enhancer model is
now able to like pick them up so you can
see that like as the model goes far away
the enhancer model is able to capture
this whereas the CNN model is no longer
able to capture this
and finally one uh I think very
interesting experiment that they had in
the paper was they were also able to
like you know predict promote or
enhancer uh inferences and that
prediction was actually on par with
experimented data so this suggests that
using this machine learning model we can
sidestep a lot of these wet lab
experiments and get like key details
which could be super useful
um so yeah so very quickly uh I'm sorry
I feel like cram fruit proteins and
genomics applications over here uh but I
think what you would see is that overall
when you look at clinical proteins and
genomic applications uh we see that
Transformers have incredible potential
potential in biomedicine uh and with
clinical applications I think the
challenges are perhaps more centered
around data and evaluation uh but on the
proteins and genomics side I think there
are some extremely interesting
opportunities to innovate on the
architecture and finally as I said there
are incredible bi-directional learning
opportunities I think the problem of you
know modeling long-range interactions
that's useful Beyond proteins Beyond
genomics I think it's useful in genomics
and so I think any architecture
improvement over here can Inspire wider
progress in AI so I think that's a big
reason to work on this
um any questions so far
sorry I covered a lot of ground over
here uh apologies for that but I think
these are super cool papers and you
should go back and read them
um so very finally I want to maybe spend
a couple of minutes touching upon how I
see the future of biomedical AI evolving
um overall I believe it's not a question
of like if AI will transform biomedicine
I think it's rather a question of when
and how
um and I think the very specific thesis
I have over here is given the nature of
biomedical data and how multimodal
nature and with all the progress and
Transformers self supports learning
large language models I think we have an
incredibly powerful process like
framework to like Leverage all the
solutions at scale and like truly build
foundational medical AI models
um so I think that is incredibly
exciting
and uh
so I'm not I think it's you've already
been over here for far too long so I'm
not going to ask you to recognize these
people but they're actually famous
Physicians scientists some of them went
on to Nobel prizes and so
I think what I want to say over here is
there's no reason for a scientist to be
different from a physician they can be
combined together and that's what we I
also want to like convey with our AI
systems as well we don't have to like
separate clinical applications and you
know biological applications I think
when we combine them together we are
going to discover a lot of new insights
and I think that's going to accelerate
biomedical research and internally to
new discoveries and which is kind of
like you know be used to eradicate
diseases
um Advanced human health span and
generally Drive human potential forward
uh sure I think the rightmost one is
Alexander Fleming
um and then Jonas salak and then
so Fleming is penicillin salt gas polio
and Ehrlich was a bunch of different
stuff
and so maybe I'll ask this question to
all of you which field of AI do you
think will which field do you think AI
will win the first Nobel Prize in
uh you don't have to answer just think
okay
so economics is not available
or something
that's right um so I also feel the same
way and I hope the overwhelming majority
of you also think that it's going to be
in medicine and uh I'm going to end on
that note uh huge thank you to all my
collaborators and teammates for most
importantly allowing me to like steel
slides
um and then also thank you to all of you
for like patiently listening over here
hopefully this was helpful